it's a new year new batch of movies what
am I looking forward to okay guys loti
keying in on this one I wasn't sure I
was even gonna do this video but I
decided I did one last year I'll doing
this year and this is my most
anticipated movies for 2016 now normally
something like this would be a top 10
but I'm just doing the same rules that
he did last year which is I'm not just
throwing up stuff that I'm hopeful we go
I'm just putting up stuff that I am
genuinely excited for so by that
criteria I've got seven that I want to
talk about that are coming out this year
now there's still plenty of other stuff
that I plan to see and there's lots of
stuff that I am hopeful for but being
hopeful that something will be good is
not the same as being genuinely excited
about it so these are the seven that I'm
excited about first up Xmen apocalypse
this was one that just kind of barely
gets there because honestly I am not the
biggest fan of apocalypse the villain I
didn't like the Age of Apocalypse
storyline particularly but I love Oscar
Isaac and I've never seen him give a bad
performance so his casting as apocalypse
goes a long way towards sort of
alleviating the problems I would
normally have and I really enjoyed x-men
days of future past so I'm really
looking forward to the follow-up number
six the Huntsman winters war this might
seem like a strange one but honestly I
really like Snow White and the Huntsman
except for one thing and that was
kristen stewart and that's not just a
bias because she was in Twilight oh I
know a lot of people just have it out
for her because of that honestly she
just dragged that movie down and it the
movie would have been so much better if
they just stuck with the girl who played
the young Snow White in like the first
10 minutes or whatever she was so much
more lively and energetic in the you
know beacon of life enjoy all the things
that they said so I was but Kristen
Stewart just absolutely was not so the
idea that we're gonna revisit that world
and that feeling that vibe but remove
the one thing that didn't work in the
first version yeah I'm absolutely on
board for that number five Doctor
Strange now we still don't know very
much about this which is the reason it's
not higher up on my list but Marvel
doing straight up magic with Benedict
Cumberbatch we've had the first releases
of the image
great I'm just really I can't not be
excited for pretty much everything that
Marvel does at this point because they
haven't had a complete fall down yet and
yeah I'm just I'm really excited to see
how this is gonna go number four
deadpool this will probably be the first
movie i see in the theaters this year I
always felt Ryan Reynolds was a terrific
hassing choice for Deadpool I'm just so
glad he's gonna get the chance to do the
character properly and it really does
look like they're doing it properly
based off the trailers and certainly the
marketing campaign has been really
ingenious it just feels like everybody's
head is in the right place for this cuz
if you're gonna do this you got to kind
of be crazy with it and it looks like
just the right amount of crazy number
three Suicide Squad now I Batman V
Superman is not on this list cuz I have
a lot of reservations I'm really nervous
about that but Ozzie Suicide Squad just
looks much more fun it looks energized
it looks lively in a way that batman be
superman just honestly doesn't and
regardless of whether or not batman v
superman is any good I really just get
the feel that having this be villains
and having characters like harley quinn
and Captain Boomerang will give it the
license to just cut loose a little bit
because these are character because
their bills these are characters who
just used to going after what they want
and getting in fun and enjoyment these
aren't burdened by the weight of
responsibilities like no they do what
they want I want to see them do what
they like to do I want to have fun this
looks fun number two captain america
civil war I'm not gonna say that Marvel
can do no wrong but i will say Marvel
has not done wrong by me yet so yeah
pretty high expectations for this one I
do actually think i have to say the
captain america the winter soldier is my
favorite Marvel film so far I really do
think thinking on it now that it did
surpass the first Avengers in my mind so
I am really stoked for the follow-up and
I'm really excited to see how the new
characters that are getting introduced
are going to be integrated and just to
see the split between the characters
that we already know and see how they
fall and how it all plays out I'm just
really excited I'm so glad the Russo
brothers are back for this go because
they handled the last
one so awesomely and my number one
probably would not have even been on
this list if I done in a month ago and
that is rogue one a Star Wars story yes
I had so much fun with the force awakens
that I am just so excited that there's
gonna be another Star Wars movie within
a year and I'm actually kind of really
excited by the fact that it's not
episode 8 now i'm willing to wait longer
for that but just i am now fully
invested and excited to be back in this
universe again and I want more I want
give me what you got and this is more
star wars and right now at this moment
in time I'm craving more Star Wars just
feel like by calling it a Star Wars
story they'll just let it stand as its
own thing and I'm really hoping them
like that's what these sort of little
side serves will be they'll be
completely self-contained it's not going
to be part of a separate series but a
fully self-contained story with in Star
Wars that actually really excites me the
more that I think about it so that is my
picks for the movies I am most excited
for in 2016 what movies are you most
excited for whatever they are drop
something down in the comments please
remember to like subscribe share this
with your friends you can follow me on
twitter at council of geeks check out
the council of geeks podcast on iTunes
and stitcher and until next time this
council is adjourned
Oh